hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast 3d dilemma of this
century
presented by natalier as gone professor
of psychiatry and behavioral sciences
obstetrics and gynaecology director
Center for Neuroscience in women's
health Stanford University School of
Medicine hi I'm Alexis Krause of lab
routes and I'll be your moderator for
today's event we are delighted
super-users educational web seminar
presented by lab roots laggards is the
leading scientific social networking
website and producer of educational
virtual events and webinars
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on that ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your question into
the drop down box that appears on the
screen Lancer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation please click
on the help desk button located in the
promotional board at the bottom center
of your screen or use the ask a question
box to let us know that you're having a
problem this presentation is educational
and thus offers continuing education
credits please click on the continuing
education credits tab located in the top
right corner of the presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
Roz dawn I will now turn the
presentation over to her
okay great so hello everyone my name is
natalja razgon I'm a professor of
psychiatry and obstetrics and
gynaecology at Stanford School of
Medicine and today we will be talking
about the salient issues plaguing our
societies in the developed world and in
all over the world actually which are
the mean somatic and neurological
diseases of the 21st century
those are dementia diabetes and
depression without talking necessarily
about the prevalences and and some kind
of a statistical numbers I want to dive
right in in the discussion of the common
mechanisms which underlie all these
three illnesses and were of course all
aware of the costs enormous cost to
society and individual as well as
families associated with having one or
more than one of these illnesses so the
mechanistic explanation behind the
development of major illnesses all boils
down to the concept of stress and
effects of stress on the various systems
in the body stress is a word which has
been used very colloquially for a very
long time but it has a very strong
biological foundation and very innate
and complicated ways of addressing
various processes in individual systems
and then in the body as a whole so this
slide on a potential pictorial of how
the stress may affect various systems is
truly a kind of a 30,000 mile view of
the major life events such as for
example trauma or abuse versus
environmental stressors which could
range from
the working environment to the
socioeconomic status such as poverty or
being in a war zone or having an adverse
upbringing in the childhood to the
physiological responses which all of
course them from the brain and affect
individual target organs the concept of
accumulation of these negative stressors
or influences along the life is known as
a concept of other stasis and the Alice
thesis is the process in which certain
events affect the body and then do not
necessarily completely go away so hence
their notion of the allostatic load or
as experiences which mount in an image
individual the appropriate wave
management of stress is called
adaptation and so they what we will be
looking as maladaptive ways the body and
specifically the brain the central
nervous system and mean diseases
affecting it respond to stress so
there are a number of major major
mechanisms which are well known to
neuroscientists to psychiatrist
neurologists and internal medicine
specialists and those are the kind of a
clusters of diseases of the brain those
are associated with maladaptive function
of cognition of emotional regulation and
they could be mediated by the exact same
mechanisms such as for example
inflammation or cortisol toxicity with
excess production of cortisol the
oxidative stress and the metabolic
dysfunction which we will talk today in
more detail about and same exact
mechanisms underlie not only diseases as
I said of this central nervous system of
the brain but also metabolic disorders
such as diabetes or obesity immune
diseases in cardiovascular disease so
the main pathophysiological condition
which is at the center of these
illnesses and pathological conditions is
called insulin resistance so I will be
spending some time in trying to dispel
the notion of what insulin resistance is
and how it might be a very pertinent and
modifiable risk factor in treating
diseases of central nervous system so
you can see on this slide insulin
resistance is about well established in
various illnesses from polycystic
ovarian syndrome to obesity and various
other issues of course what we do know
well is that one of the most known
outcomes of standing and some
resistances diabetes but in truth is
only one of the major diseases but
independent of that insulin resistance
can lead to depression can lead to
dementia and can lead to cardiovascular
disease
so I will skip that slide and go
straight to the definition of what
insult resistance really is it's a
condition in which tissue responsiveness
to the normal action of insulin is
impaired and what it truly means is that
the peripheral or central insulin
receptors are not sensitive enough to
bind the circulating amount of insulin
and therefore there's an insulin
free insulin unbound insulin to the
receptor circulating in the system that
is in many ways a condition which may be
leading to the hyperglycemia eventually
but may be can condition which affects
an individual for years or decades prior
to evolving further one of the important
things for clinicians in the audience
would be that the insulin resistance may
or may not be a consequence of weight
gain and so the notion which is widely
entertained in the various clinical
disciplines right now that obesity
equals diabetes equals insulin
resistance is really not correct so and
we'll talk about that later so these are
the again a pictorial mechanisms of how
what happens in the various target
organs when insulin resistance occurs so
the adipose tissue is one of the most
important target areas in the body which
is responsible for production of free
fatty acids free fatty acids decrease
the insulin action and that could be
mediated into three different peripheral
targets one is the skeletal muscle the
other is another type of adipose tissue
which could be an abdominal adiposity or
what we call a central adiposity and the
third is liver
of the target eventually there is a
decreased production of glucose in terms
of being you could actively utilized
inhibition of the lipolysis and
increased glucose output so in overall
outcome there will be spilling glucose
in a blood what was known as a
hyperglycemia and dyslipidemia
what is fascinating and not as
well-known as the condition of insulin
resistance which had been coined by
recently departed Gerald reven who was
our Stanford professor of endocrinology
which was coined by him about thirty
years ago a syndrome X but the insulin
resistance independent of periphery
occurs in the central nervous system and
that is much less examined at this point
in humans however there are a number of
studies which suggest that that there
isn't a correlation between the
depression and the condition of insulin
resistance keeping of course in mind
that in humans we do not measure insulin
resistance in the brain per se but
assessing it as a central correlate of
peripheral insulin resistance so the
high prevalence of depression in
patients with primary insulin resistance
such as for example polycystic ovarian
syndrome or pre-diabetes or in diabetics
as we know which is a long-standing of
course condition of insulin resistance
there is about 60% prevalence of
depression even the non diabetic
patients with major depression or often
have insulin resistance which may
persist even after treatment of
depression is successful the certain
mechanistic underpinnings of that is
reduced insulin transport into the brain
through the blood-brain barrier and the
glucose deprivation which may lead to
the impairment of brain brain function
and that impairment of course
individually affects the brain and some
people it manifests as a cognitive
impairment or decline or depression and
the detrimental effects on behavior
influence the Equality of the glycemic
control making the notion of recognizing
in some resistance in patients with the
neurological and psychiatric illnesses
all too important so there are number of
other
a major risk factors because of which
it's really truly a paramount for us to
identify insult resistance early and
that is the risk for dementia as we know
dementia is a very growing problem and
will teach epidemic proportion in a
couple of decades and it's one of the
most horrible illnesses which Rob's the
person of their individual memory and
tremendously disrupts the family and
society so age is one of the main
critical risk factors for cognitive
decline but what is becoming more and
more evident that having insulin
resistance may impair cognition at the
younger age and now even at an age when
people are not at all or decades removed
from the age-related risk for cognitive
impairment I will move on to the next
slide to show you that data from one of
our older studies which was published
three year four years ago now looking at
the insulin resistance as it's measured
in a blood in the state of the science
form which is called SSP G or it's a
basically an insulin clamp and the
cognitive performance in patients who
had history of depressive disorders you
could see that there were a number of
individuals who were younger than age 45
so the mean age was 48 but ranges were
from 19 to 71 and I will tell you why
it's important those are were
well-educated people who were not
currently depressed and there is a lot
of them were in fact insulin resistant
the weight in these individuals was also
ranging between 19 and 49 which is a
wide range but the mean of a of weight
in those individuals was in the
overweight category
so what we saw here was that the
non-diabetic adults of pretty wide age
range both genders who had a history of
mood disorder and were cognitively
intact had uh if that had been evaluated
for the correlation between the extent
of their insulin secretion and glucose
utilization and specific cognitive
performance on in various models so in
one of the models we looked at the
effects specifically of the clamp on the
cognitive performance and in another
were looked at the effects of the weight
and just to remind the listener is again
as I said before there is no hundred
percent linear correlation between the
weight and the insulin resistance so
what we found was that correlations were
different by the age group in
individuals who were 45 and older and I
will start with the right part of the
slide being more overweight was
significantly associated with a change
in the executive function as measured by
the FS IQ sub test but being insulin
resistant in those older adults was not
predictive of any problems on the
cognitive performance whereas in
individuals ages 19 to 45 so those were
very young adults those had the opposite
effect where being overweight was not
associated with any cognitive
performance but being insulin resistance
was associated with problems in the same
test of cognitive flexibility so to
conclude from this study and to kind of
make a take-home message point is that
young individuals who have insulin
resistance may have worsened cognitive
performance even if it's with them
age-related norm in the absence of the
weight gain whereas being obese in the
older age is associated with both
cognitive performance even in the
absence of this metabolic dysfunction of
insulin resistance moving along to
disorders of effective regulation or
depressive illnesses so their number of
studies done in our lab and many other
labs over the years over the last 15
years which accumulate a certain number
of experiments and contribute to the
evidence that patients with depression
may in fact have profound contribution
of the insulin resistance to their
illness one of the more intriguing and
and kind of difficult things to accept
is that the age at which insulin
resistance may affect mood disorders
actually also moving unfortunately to
the younger age and the study which I
will not show yet because it's still
ongoing suggests that even in
adolescence with depression we can see
already neural correlates of insulin
resistance but for now it would suffice
to say that insulin resistance is often
accompanied by depressive symptomatology
and that patients with depression health
biomarkers associated with insulin
resistance so the next question would be
naturally okay so if there is this an
overlapping pathophysiological platform
what would happen if we treat the
patient with depression for the insulin
resistance so what would happen it would
try to resolve in fluent assistance and
depressed individual and I will show you
here the study
which were published a few years ago as
well on the air Don of the PRG agonist
which is the insulin sensitizing agent
in this case it was pioglitazone versus
placebo in patients who had in fact
being treated for depression and
remained depressed
despite being treated for it what we
found was simple basically if if you add
PRG agonist to the treatment as usual
for depression over three months period
there is an appreciable decline in the
depression severity and so a lot of
patients respond to that medication so
therefore there is a improvement in
depressive symptomatology
as a result of reduction in insulin
resistance what is even more interesting
that there is an innate effect back to
the just previously mentioned study on
the age-related cognitive performance
the age effect in this in this study was
that the younger individuals respond
better so there is a more enhanced
improvement in depression severity in a
younger group than in those who were a
little bit older
now I will move move that goalpost
a little bit further and talk about the
biomarkers of stress and the allostatic
load as they may underlie the responses
and be a mechanistic goalpost for the
prediction of the response to the
resolving insulin resistance in
disorders of brain telomeres have been
on a de for post of the research for the
last fifteen to twenty years they were
discovered by Elizabeth Blackburn here
at UCSF which she received a Nobel Prize
we all know that telomeres are basically
the caps of the regular chromosomes they
are known to be associated with
accelerated aging and could be a
biomarkers of multiple processes
associated with premature aging of
course one of the processes we would
talk about today would be inflammation
and oxidative stress and insulin
resistance and so then their
multiplicity of various studies
suggesting that telomeres are viable and
fairly easy obtainable predictor for the
effects of the cardiovascular disease or
diabetes or dementia in the brain
especially in older individuals but
again looking at the younger individuals
in trying to provide a an individualized
approach targeting the these processes
early in life so we looked at the
telomeres and I will move again the
slide without necessarily going into the
details of this but just to show the
another study which was published from
the lab on the telomere links as a
predictor of response to this
pioglitazone the PRG agonist in patients
with unremitted depression so in the
same study which I was
describing a few minutes ago basically
we measured the telomere length in
patients prior to them being treated and
examined the correlation between that
length of telomeres and insulin
resistance status at baseline and then
at the end of the study
so what we found was that there was a a
positive correlation between the
telomere length and insulin resistance
at baseline what it really means is that
people who have who exhibit metabolic
dysfunction have already shorter
telomeres therefore having a bigger
allostatic load and risk for accelerated
aging furthermore we found that those
who had longer telomeres at baseline
improved better in depression severity
in the group assigned to the
pioglitazone but not necessarily in
placebo so that kind of suggests that
allosteric load is reduced by the
improvement in the metabolic dysfunction
and that the biomarker of our static
load could be a significant and accurate
predictor for that response overall to
say that it also helps patients with
depression to receive a better treatment
and to be hopefully are more protected
from the premature brain aging so to
take it together I would say that there
are a number of complexities which I was
just kind of lightly touching and giving
you a sample menu today on the
interactions among various systems and
pathways which ultimately result in the
three mean maladaptive
conditions those are diseases of
effective regulation which is depression
the cognitive function which may
independently lead to dementia and the
metabolic dysfunction which may lead to
all all of the above plus diabetes and
cardiovascular disease so the notion
before the scientists right now is to
really try to untie those connections
and to understand we're in an
individualized medicine approach we can
address the negative effects of stress
and try to protect individuals from risk
of developing any or either of these
illnesses
or for the practitioners I guess would
be an important take-home messages anand
if excuse me an identification of
patients who might be at risk and the
identification in the psychiatric
offices of course not the easy one but
for the private practitioners who are in
a primary care field or internal
medicine field or even the neurology
field that would be a viable way of
measuring the proxy marker which is not
requesting even a blood draw and that is
the assessment of the central adiposity
if you recall the slide I was showing in
the very beginning of the adipose
tissues actively secreting free fatty
acids and potentially leading to the
insulin resistance the central adiposity
is one of the more accurate biomarkers
of metabolic dysfunction with the west
literature now supporting the predictive
value and a risk for cardiovascular
disease diabetes and even TNS illnesses
the easiest way to do it is to measure
the waist circumference and the you can
see here the abdominal obesity or that
central adiposity definitions which
comply with the notion of the metabolic
syndrome are widely used in various
assessments of individuals at risk
um the other way to assess for the
presence of insulin resistance is really
a a lab work done in the morning for the
fasting plasma glucose and fasting
plasma insulin which yields what is
known as a homeostatic model assessment
ratio or Homa and that could be easily
obtained in any lab those targets would
be an appropriate primary therapeutic
target and should be part of the
multi-faceted assessment of the disease
whether it's an illness of the central
nervous system or the primary
cardiovascular or diabetes
pathology finally treatment of outcomes
in mood disorders should anticipate a
probability of less favorable outcome in
individuals who also have a concomitant
metabolic dysfunction and I think that
that would kind of make a much better
solution for those who treat patients
with mood disorders for months and years
without much success because I think
that assessment was in for the
individual metabolic function may yield
an optimal results and management of the
depression so our non-pharmacological II
we think interventions associated with
diet exercise and stress reduction now
with we can provide or at least offer
for consideration the pathophysiological
platform trying to justify the use of
these very commonly advised
interventions and to create a direction
for future studies looking at the
specific molecular targets in the brain
and peripherally as a result of stress
reduction exercise or diet so this
probably would be sufficient to finish I
just want to kind of acknowledge people
who work in lab
and who contributed to this research as
well as collaborators in our vast
research network of centers around the
world and the specific group of people I
mentioned here represent the network
which we now actively working in and
it's called psychopathology and
allostatic load across the lifespan of
pails
with participation from Rockefeller mont
sinaï South Carolina John Hopkins
Toronto UCSF UCLA University of Michigan
and the University of Amsterdam so with
that I will stop and take questions
Thank You dr. Raskin for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on that ask a question drop down box
located on the far left to your
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on your screen
and click the send button well answer as
many questions as we have time for so
let's get started our first question is
what are the common underlying
mechanisms among 3 D so the 3 D which to
again reiterate the diabetes dementia
and depression are all guided by the mul
adaptive allostatic load and conditions
of metabolic dysfunction such as insulin
resistance oxidative stress and
inflammation today we were discussing
specifically the insulin resistance as
the example of those underlying
mechanisms but certainly the
inflammatory cytokines the biomarkers of
oxidative stress and others are also a
common pathogenic platforms under all
these three major illnesses
how does insulin resistance manifest in
central nervous system diseases
so that's a great question because we
still as I said in my lecture and I and
I hope that I was able to really
emphasize that point that insulin
resistance in humans at this point is
measured in the peripheral blood and
what we're trying to assess are the
neural correlates in various models of
psychopathology for example in patients
who have dementia or patients who have
MCI or in patients who have depression
bipolar disorder etc so we're looking at
the changes in the neural biomarkers
such as for example regional metabolism
in various regions of interest which are
implicated in these diseases or the
connectivity between the main networks
responsible for the cognitive Selective
cognitive performance or affective
regulations such as hippocampus a
prefrontal cortex etc so the effects of
insulin resistance in the brain per se
still await development of more precise
ways of measuring it in in vivo in a
human and that's one of the main intense
research areas our lab our network and
many other networks around the world are
focused on
gun it looks like we have time for one
more question what happens to the
central nervous system if insulin
resistance is treated
so that's that's again kind of a
question which is answered at this point
with the assessment of the peripheral
insulin resistance but what we do see
nowadays is that there there are certain
improvements in connectivity for example
between the hippocampus and the
prefrontal cortex understanding that
those are major pathways subserve a
motional regulation and cognition
executive function attention etc so we
can say that by resolving insulin
resistance we might improve the
collaborate collaborative work of
various pathways in the brain what we
don't know yet is whether it happens in
the periphery independent from the
central nervous system and we do know
that whether we understand it fully or
not but insulin itself as a hormone is a
very important nura protective agent in
the brain and so we would be very
interested to assess accurately than
your protective effects of insulin in
specific areas regions in the brain but
that is something we need to try to
answer in the future with the
development of more sophisticated
individualized precision medicine
assessment
I would like to once again thank dr.
Raskin for her presentation
I would also like to thank laborat 'days
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing for June of 2018 you
will receive an email from laboratory
available for replay please share that
announcement with your colleagues who
may have missed today's live event
that's all for now thank you for joining
us and we hope to see you again soon
goodbye